and i was watching a lot of your content
and i've i've seen you with you and bill
nye and and you know what i did when you
were speaking all i did is focus on bill
nye i'm like when he gets upset his
facial expressions i don't know if you
did you see that or no have you seen it
the way he was getting agitated by it
was just entertaining to me to see and
then you know i you know i've been
following this uh topic of climate
change i think it's actually the next
thing that's gonna
uh be used by the media a lot i think
for some people that are creating
content i have a feeling they may if
there was covid that were videos that
were
being taken down i think climate change
maybe some of the next videos that may
be taken down in censor but at the same
time
what i want to get with you today
is
there are a lot of people that are very
smart
who
fully believe
this is taking place it's coming and i'm
not talking about greta thonberg i'm not
talking about aoc
i'm not even putting al gore in that mix
these are politicians uh i'm not talking
president obama who said this is the
this is the biggest crisis that we
should pay attention to i'm not talking
about bernie sanders bette midler
um not john kerry not jane fonda not
leonardo dicaprio but i'm talking about
and elon musk the way he explained it
you know the the i don't know if you've
seen the 12-minute speech he gives when
he breaks down what's going on with the
temperature we're two degrees to some of
us may not be a big deal
and then he says you know five degrees
uh of new york city five degrees has he
explained it new york city would be
under ice
uh minus five degrees and new york city
would be underwater plus five degrees
and that's not just a regular guy who
says that he's a guy that'll call out
[ __ ] so when he says that he makes
me think but prior to us getting into
the questions that we have here if you
don't mind the audience who maybe
doesn't know your story give us a little
bit about your background and how you
came to the conclusion of this may just
be a hoax and maybe they're selling it
from the other side as the next massive
crisis i will i actually just want to
say one thing about uh
about musk
fascinating figure i i don't know what
year that speech you're referring to do
you remember when it was done that oh
i can pull it up i can see what euro was
it
right now what his views are now on
climate post covid but elon musk is was
in a position for years he wasn't five
years ago that was five years ago yeah
but he wasn't always the rebel
especially the free speech rebel you see
today because maybe he wasn't needed to
be but essentially he was relying on a
lot of government contracts a lot of the
of support that he sort of played along
he was a big promoter of climate change
fears uh and it'd be interesting to see
now what he's doing there the two
degrees and we can talk about it later
is he's just using with the u.n when
that number the two degrees celsius
temperature was literally pulled out of
thin air
just to give the public something to
latch on to this was admitted by top u.n
scientists in the climate gate emails so
all the unm musk what you're referring
to is saying oh two degrees is what the
u.n says and here's what could might may
happen if that scenario it's kind of
like saying we're going to go on a
family vacation but if the car hits a
tractor-trailer here's what could happen
and they're going to show dead bodies in
the highway i mean that's that's
basically that's easy it's simple it's
cheap politics and i and i like elon
musk now same by the way just to say
elon musk robert f kennedy jr uh these
are people they're huge climate fear
promoters in my new book i publicly
essentially forgive them especially
robert f kennedy junior one of the jail
climate skeptics in an interview i did
with him he said we belong at the hague
with three square three squares and a
cot with all the other war criminals and
i forgive him because the way he came
around on on covet and was just one of
the most incredible anti-tyrannical
anti-tyranny speakers oh he got censored
by instagram by everybody i mean we've
had him on multiple times and every time
videos would get flagged on what he had
to say and this is the number one
environmental attorney in america
apparently based on what a lot of people
would say so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you